it's actually not my job to answer your
questions are you prepared to call h a
terror group is it possible to have a
rational I've asked you two questions
should a mass stay in power and are they
a terror group you're refusing to answer
either of them that is very telling talk
TV is the only place where you get the
truth you've done a book on poetry
poetry and music for the many I love
poetry we can agree on
that
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk
[Music]
TV toan appears Morgan uncensored from
New York City it's been 100 days since
the Hamas attacks plunged Israel into a
brutal War and the Middle East into
mounting chaos I'll talk exclusively to
an emotional Thomas hand who mourned his
kidnapped 8-year-old daughter only to
discover she was still alive and then
she came
home plus Sub-Zero chills blast Iowa as
resident Republicans picked their
Presidential nominee K Nikki Haley surge
freeze Trump in his tracks is Ronda
santis about his put his campaign on Ice
we'll know tonight the race for the
White House starts right
here live from New York this is Pierce
Morgan uncensored
well good evening from New York and
welcome to peers Morgan un sensitive the
next few days will be seismic for a
presidential election here that will
itself change the world and the
decisions now being taken in the Middle
East could dramatically change the world
too and the next president of course
will oversee them it's now 100 days
since Hamas terrorists invaded Israel
raping killing and kidnapping civilians
in a barbaric medieval Rampage to those
now ferociously criticizing the
escalation in the region remember who
escalated this in the first place Hamas
shattered peace in the Middle East and
they knew exactly what the response
would
be well yesterday they reminded the
world exactly what they are releasing a
sick video of three of the 136 hostages
still trapped in Gaza including Noah
aamani a student kidnapped from a rave
on the back of a motorbike while her
mother now battles terminal cancer at
home well tonight Hamas released another
video this time just of Noah and this
time she she was taped saying that the
two men who appeared alongside her
yesterday are now dead make no mistake
the vile people who took these innocent
people as hostages are responsible for
the Catalyst of Horrors we're now
witnessing there's no moral defense for
hamamass but many of the pro palestine's
protesters who took the streets again
this weekend in New York Washington DC
and London do have a point the civilian
death toll in Gaza is testing the upper
limits of proportionality more people
people are dying every day than in any
other conflict in modern history
Israel's no plan for life beyond the war
except occupation or Anarchy and the
nightmare scenario of a conflict
engulfing the region is edging Closer To
Grim reality with us-led strikes on
Yemen and fears of war in Lebanon prime
minister Netanyahu pandering to
extremists who prop up his government
says nothing not even the international
court of justice will stop
him 100 days to the atrocious day where
our citizens were butchered and abducted
we continue with the war to the end to
the full victory until we achieve all
the
objectives liquidating the Kamas
bringing back their hostages and the
promise that Gaza will never become yet
again a threat to Israel we're going to
bring back safety to the South and to
the north no one is going to stop
us neither the ha not the AES of evil
and nobody
else well reports here in the US say
that President Biden hasn't even spoken
to net and Yahoo for more than three
weeks simp because he won't listen to
his calls for caution well he should and
soon Israel is vital to the West it's
the only democracy in the Middle East
it's a buw walk against Iran and its
proxies it's supposed to be a safe haven
for the Jewish people after centuries of
persecution so yes America is right to
defend Israel just as Israel has a right
to defend itself but it can't be handed
a blank check signed in Palestinian
blood Israel has dropped almost 30,000
bombs and shells on Gaza in a 100 days
eight times more than the US aimed at
Iraq in six years of war it's true that
every war in human history has taken
many lives including many innocent
civilian lives but 24,000 people in 3
months God knows how many more beneath
the rubble is that still a proportionate
response every day of this war I've
asked that question of many guess from
afar it's look increasingly like the
answer is becoming no it's true that the
Allied Forces killed masses of innocent
people in Dresden in Hiroshima and
Beyond to defeat the Nazis in World War
II but that was 79 years ago we created
systems of international law to make
sure the atrocities on both sides would
never be repeated it's true this was
Israel's 9/11 and there was no public
appetite for restraint back then but
that yearning for justice took us into
two disastrous and deadly Wars shouldn't
Israel learn from those mistakes and
it's true that Hamas is an oppressive
misogynistic terror group which hides in
tunnels and uses its people as human
Shields but 85% of the entire population
has now been displaced 70% of gaza's
homes and half of its buildings are
damaged or destroyed only eight of its
36 hospitals are running 2third of
schools and 100 mosques have been
damaged by Israel's bombardment is
destruction on this scale really what it
takes to eradicate Hamas and if the
answer is yes why are they still in
charge when will Israel provide some
evidence that it has a plan for life
after this war for the gazans and for
Israel and that that plan is remotely
workable there are major unanswered
questions about this war with major
consequences for the world but the most
visceral consequences of the last 100
days have fallen most heavily on the
shoulders of the people behind the
numbers on both sides people like Thomas
hand whose daughter Emily turned nine
during days in Hamas captivity as a
hostage Thomas H's emotional interviews
brought home the reality of this war for
those of us who can only imagine the
pain including most movingly when he
wrongly assumed that she was dead they
just said we found
Emily uh she's
dead and I went
yes that was the best possibly that I
was hoping for woman she was either
dead or in
Gaza and if you know anything about what
they do to people in
Gaza that is worse than death so death
was a blessing and absolute
blessing well thankfully it turned out
that the real blessing was that Emily
wasn't dead she wasn't actually
mistreated in the way that Thomas feared
most at the hands of her mass and
eventually she was returned to him and
people like Thomas hand are what this
war should never lose sight of we should
never forget that there are still 136
hostages being held in captivity it's
also why Israel must be better than the
evil is trying to
overcome well spoke to Thomas hand and
his daughter Emily shortly before became
on air today well I'm delighted to say
I'm joined Now by Thomas hand and by his
daughter to Emily so Thomas it's
fantastic to see you both it's great uh
to see you because I I guess because I'm
a father I have a 12-year-old girl
myself I'm Irish um and so your story of
so many stories in this awful War
resonated with me very personally and I
can't tell you how thrilled I was when
you were reunited with Emily and let me
start just by ask asking you about that
moment for you what was it like for you
to finally after everything you'd been
through thinking she was dead then
hearing she might be alive then hearing
she was being released the moment that
we all watched on video when she ran
towards you what were you
thinking
H um it was it was
unbelievable uh it was a
miracle um when we were waiting they
were were supposed to have released her
much earlier than that during the day
according to our
agreements but uh we waited a long time
and uh during that time of course I'm
thinking something's gone wrong
something's going to go wrong either on
the Hamas side or on our own government
side the Israeli government side you
know you just until I saw
the color of her
eyes uh I could
not I couldn't hope I had to keep my
feelings and emotions
down I can see her sitting there she
doesn't speak much English um you
brought her up uh speaking Hebrew um but
she wanted to sit in on this interview
with you which I guess may be an
indication just generally of not wanting
to leave your side very much how's how
has she been doing Emily since she got
back
uh to be very honest she's doing
incredibly well um kids are just
amazingly
resilient um Her speech is almost back
at full volume she's eating like a horse
she sleeps well not not too many
nightmares
um not too many
nightmares um
the occasional one but uh sometimes I I
just watch her in theight and uh when I
see
her crunching up her face I I wake her
up break the
Nightmare and how are you doing Thomas
because you've been through so much in
the last 100 days your peaceful life was
suddenly just thrown to pieces in so
many ways and I've come to some of the
other ways that people may not even
realize but how how are you
doing um I'm actually doing very well
um I actually wasn't in a great position
before this all started mentally
depression um but because of it
all it's made me uh
Stronger uh if you can get through this
you can I can get through through
anything um
Ken uh all the interviews all the
television interviews the newspaper
interviews your you're
reliving not just that day my day
started the evening
before um so I'm living from the 6th the
evening of the 6th to whenever the
interview took place like I'm maybe
going to have to relive it again for you
from the 6th till this date and so I was
at one point
talking 12 hours a day every day of the
week and uh that's basically what you do
in therapy it was a free free
Psychotherapy so I'm much stronger on
October the
7th I know that we know now that Emily
of course was having a sleepover with
her friend Hiller um and her mother was
to play a very important role with what
then happened happened with Emily and
we'll come to that but what was your
first inkling that something very bad
was going
down
okay um
right
um yeah it was it was Instinct it was uh
there was no uh there was no way to work
out something like that was happening it
was just it was was a feeling a feeling
of
dread something not right on that day um
for since we pulled out of Gaza in
2005 we've been peppered hammered with
um Kasam Rockets from
Gaza all the
time um and we're used to that we just
get the we get the siren
uh we got it's saber adom it comes over
the whole intercom um
connections even on your phone saor D sa
a d means red color so wherever you are
you look for the nearest uh bomb shelter
and get there pretty swiftly we have uh
in kibuts we have 11
seconds which isn't a long time but you
don't panic and we at first you panicked
you ran like clappers but
um as the years go by you just drop
everything in a second there's no Panic
you just swiftly get there um 11 seconds
is quite a long
time the full horror of what is actually
unfurling took quite a while to be
understood by people the kind of
medieval barbarism that was going on but
what was the moment Thomas for you that
you realized that Emily was
onone
um not for a few days later my I'm sorry
but my time scale is uh completely
gone uh these last three months seemed
like a year already so I have no time
reference anymore but uh within a week I
was informed that
um uh she'd been found dead in
theuts
well coming up more from my exclusive
interview with Thomas hand and his
daughter Emily that's uncensored next
live from New York
[Music]
City we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online we on your smart speaker as well
criminals to using XL Bully dogs as
weapons to threaten others no matter how
well trained most dog owners will tell
you a dog can turn do you know what I
love about to today we do it all sunak
sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the Tor love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swear an Al in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million 140
million so far so40 million so far
results nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in win is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking for a liit if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan you have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC mous man MC mous
man MC man he should be easy enough to
catch this guy shouldn't he I mean he's
got house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
fil sunak and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on behalf of the reform UK
party kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solved
this is really unfair what what what's
unfair if it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yes I'm going to do you're
going to Res yes cuz I cannot continue
my work when I say I am God I'm not
joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions are
you prepared to call h a terror group is
it possible to have a rational I've
asked you two questions should a mass
stay in power and are they a terror
group you're refusing to answer either
of them that is very telling talk TV
it's the only place where you get the
truth you've done a book on poetry
poetry and music for the many I love
poetry we can agree on
[Music]
that welcome back to uncensored live
from New York City more now from my
interview with Thomas Han and his
9-year-old daughter Emily who was
kidnapped by her Mass on October the 7th
I spoke with Thomas about the weeks he
believed his daughter was dead there was
an extraordinary interview that you gave
to Clarissa Ward at CNN I know Clarissa
used to work with her and I want to just
play a little clip from that this was
when you believed that Emily had been
killed they just said we found
Emily uh she's dead
and I went
yes that was the best possibil that I
was hoping for she was either
dead or in
Gaza and if you know anything about what
they do to people in
Gaza that is worse than death so death
was a blessing an absolute
blessing that was such an agonizing
interview to watch Thomas can you
remember yeah your feelings at that at
that point when you really did think
you'd lost her I completely understood
what you were saying but can you
remember how you
felt yeah absolutely relieved because um
in a way it was very uh prophetic and
I'm sure half the people well 90% of the
people in the world would not realize
what I was saying um how bad the Kamas
can treat treat their
hostages uh and yes death was much
better than anything that they were
going to do to her she was at peace she
was at rest I could be resting I could
be at peace I could just do the natural
process of grieving instead of what
139 hostages are held still there so all
the families and all the friends are
going through that now thankfully I
didn't have to go through that I went
through it for almost two months but
they're still there 100 days 1001 days
now and you know Thomas even as I'm I'm
speaking to you I've just been sent a
note that two more hostages have now
been confirmed to have been killed um
that's just been breaking news as I'm
talking to you which just goes to show
that the the horror of people who've now
had to wait 100 days and then to get
news like that it is it's unimaginable
to me what everyone in that position
must be going
through yeah it's an absolute nightmare
um sorry but do you do you have their
names at all yes I do I've just been
sent it now um Hamas has released a
video appearing to show bodies of two
hostages um Yosi sharabi and itai zki
who appeared alive in a
video it was they were in a video
released by the group
yesterday um in a new video the third
hostage Noah Aram aramani says the pair
were killed because of Israeli air
strikes she was obviously speaking as a
hostage herass has produced no evidence
for that claim um but this follows that
video they released
yesterday
so Noah Noah is
gone it seems that Noah's alive and was
making the video
announcement that the other two had ah
died at the hands of an Israeli air
strike right yeah
um Ellie no it wasn't Ellie it was Yosi
Yosi yes Yosi shabi and spki again they
they they they were from
kibot and uh spki was with Emily for the
whole duration of her captivity there
was nothing wrong with
him so they've killed
him okay and of course blaming the IDF
why why wouldn't you yeah well thank god
Noah is
alive and hopefully she will stay that
way so yeah and Noah's mother such a
such
a yeah I'm very I'm so sorry to have had
to told you that I just felt it was
important given you were just talking
directly about the hostages that you
should be aware of that
news oh Christ yeah and you
know uh Yosi um his brother is there as
well Ellie or he's already dead I don't
know but
um Ellie uh he saw probably saw his wife
being shot to to death and uh his
16-year-old daughter and his 13-year-old
daughter the Noya and
yel
sharabi and let me take you back Thomas
to when you discovered that Emily may be
still alive you weren't even certain but
you were told there were indications
that she might be still alive
yeah uh yeah at the time it was uh it
was the lack of evidence that she was
dead that uh there was three stages you
were either
dead uh Missing because they didn't know
where you were or confirmed as a hostage
taken away and uh because she was no
longer dead they didn't find her body
anywhere they didn't find any DNA so you
have to
presume she's missing and probably only
probably hostage in Gaza but then uh
later
on uh funny enough on the night of a
ceremony honoring the hostages some an
eyewitness came up to us someone we knew
and said she saw
Emily hila her friend and Rya the mother
being LED away to Gaza put in the back
of a truck and uh taken away so that's
when she she went through the whole
Spectrum she was dead she was missing
and then she became a hostage in
Gaza and for you having already told the
world that you would have preferred to
think that she was dead than being held
hostage that emotion for you when you
realize your worst
fear may actually now have been realized
that was like being punched in the
stomach by a professional
boxer
um yeah um your heart sank your mind
went into uh overload of what's going to
happen to her um yeah that was a that
was the worst moment out of it all the
worst just falling into that bottomless
pit of despair Ken that was awful
and the greatest Moment For You by
contrast must have been the moment that
you were told that she was going to be
released how did you hear that so I'm
sitting in the in
the in the David Hotel outside on a
chair and uh funny enough I had a
reporter sitting right next to me he
was not exactly an interview but a prein
and um I got a phone call from the Army
saying Emily's on the
list and you can imagine I wanted to
scre I wanted to jump up and
scream and I had to just keep absolutely
calm and collected and say okay right uh
thank you very much for that information
uh I'll get back to you some I
didn't there no way I wanted the
reporter to get a hint of what was going
on uh and thankfully he didn't and uh as
soon as I once I got back to the hotel
room I think I screamed the blue murder
yeah well coming up the final part of my
emotional interview with Thomas hand and
his daughter Emily that's on S next live
from New York
[Music]
City we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online R your smart speaker as well you
know what I love about to today we do it
all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the Tories love a scrap
you can almost see this coming round the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and rishy soon at the
other the police are pro Palestine that
is just not right you swearing o in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy there
needs to be one human per machine to
come and rectify beeps and the clanks
and when it goes wrong unexpected item
in bagging area I know are we only going
to be trusting sources like meta and
Google where is our unbiased news going
to come from Graham was president of the
Cambridge Union which is the rubbish
version of being president of the Oxford
Union
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking for living if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan you have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegan's about Twitter
you sons of can you please reinstate my
account thank you this is a major Summit
President Biden decided this was
important after watching a Tom Cruz
film kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down to problem solves when I say I am
God I'm not joking did you feel Elvis
was controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your question are
you prepared to call h a terror group is
it possible to have a
rational talk TV it's the only place
where you get the
truth this is talk
[Music]
TV welcome back to un senstive live from
New York City now to my final part of my
interview with Thomas hand and his
nine-year-old daughter Emily who's
released by Hamas 50 days after being
taken hostage on October the 7th the
reality Thomas of what she'd been
through was nowhere near as horrific as
you had feared um um I I don't want to
speak for you but my understanding is
there was no sign that she had been
beaten or abused in any way um I think
that's that's the case
right yep um as far as terrorist go they
were uh reasonably good uh they didn't
sexually abuse her like they've done
with many
others she wasn't raped even as a small
child which they have done to others she
wasn't beaten
tortured um they
were they were all reasonably Humane
shall we say um they they kept them on
very small rations of
food even though they had lots of food
in my head I'm thinking you know she's
not going to be getting lots of food
because probably they won't have lots of
food but um she's told me that uh no
they had lots of food they could smell
it being cooked
but they weren't given
any one day they built like they made a
a mountain of like very small
donuts a mountain of them and they they
each had uh they were given one each and
no need for
that
anyway
she you found that she her head was full
of lice for example and she was pretty
emaciated given how she had been before
um but what the biggest problem that she
faced and you faced psychological you
know I read that she believed she'd
actually been taken for a
year oh yeah but you know the old saying
uh when you're having fun time flies and
uh I guess her two months felt like a
year she wasn't enjoying it very much
yeah um most of the time they the only
um
activity that they could do was uh play
cards and uh do drawing they had to be
very very quiet there was no
conversations uh so that that would get
boring after a very short
time they were threatened at one stage
with a knife by one of the Hamas
terrorists because they were making too
much
noise uh yeah they were probably just
talking they weren't making much noise
but they were told to be be
quiet um yeah be quiet or we'll we'll
kill you with this knife is what she
said to me how do how do you say be
quiet how how do you say t
Arab she's learned Arabic while she was
away so that's you know that's always a
good thing isn't it that's amazing well
there were other tragedies for you
uh your your ex-wife narcis was killed
on October the 7th and was the mother of
of your two other children um and you
had to explain that I guess to Emily
when she came back she'd acted like a
another mother to her that must have
been an incredibly difficult thing to
do
yeah uh yeah when she was
released um and after old the hugs and
uh celebrations together uh we were
putting uh a transport Convoy uh coming
back to the hospital to get her treated
for
whatever injuries she might have and
check her physically all over and
mentally anyway
um so I said to
her uh Aiden and Natalie my two oldest
kids kids and uh her grandmother Mariana
are waiting in the in the
hospital with uh our other dog
schnitzel uh they're going to meet you
when we get there and she's uh she's
very smart she immediately went what
about
niss so
um I I was I was shocked I wasn't ready
for that so I said uh
H we don't know about niss yet just
anything to keep her away because uh I
wanted to get back to the hospital and
speak to the psychiatrist first to ask
what am I supposed to do what what
should I
say and uh I knew the answer already
I've I've been there with her actual
mother uh the best thing you can do is
tell them the truth
as hard and painful is it is to do for
you and for them
that's what you've got to do so um she
asked two more times in the van going
back to the hospital and had to just
keep her at Bay eventually we got back
to the hospital they said yes you just
got to tell her
so sat her down quietly and uh just told
her straight and uh the only reaction
she had at the time was a very sharp in
intake of breath she just
went and that was it didn't say a word
only the next night um
she she uh sobbed herself to sleep but
under the blankets on the bed like under
the duvet on the bed um obviously the
first thing you want to do is Comfort
your
child she wouldn't let me touch her
she'd forgotten how to be comforted by a
parent and that was that was very hard I
just had to um had to let her cry it
out it's incredibly touching Thomas to
watch the way Emily has been interacting
with you throughout this interview and
not least just then when she wiped away
your
tears um she's an extraordinary young
young girl isn't she
she's tougher than all of us she really
is tougher than all of us um I'm not bad
I'm very emotional
as right the way through it I've always
been emotional I'm sorry about that but
uh that's me um but she's as uh she's as
tough as Nails Thomas how do you feel
incredible about how do you feel about
the general situation now 100 days on
from the appalling terror attack atts
that hit you and so many families how do
you feel about the debate about the war
itself about Israel's response some
people feeling it's it's become
disproportionate because so many
civilians have been killed what do you
feel about
that they don't know a
thing
um
you
they we're living it
okay we're living it we have been living
it every day for 20
years you have no idea you have no right
to even speak to me have you been to
Israel
ever any one of you saying it's
disproportionate has any one of you come
to see a path hiide in this
country it doesn't exist you idiots it
doesn't
exist look at all the road signs come
come and look at all the road
signs it's in Hebrew it's in Arabic and
it's in English all the buses all the
buses with the electronic writing have
Hebrew Arabic and English do you
honestly think the country would go to
that much trouble having all the road
signs in all three
languages it wouldn't if we were a
parde you wouldn't do that you wouldn't
waste your money for crying out
loud come to come to any Hospital in
this in this country come to any school
in this country come to any City in this
country you'll
find
Arabs women female Arabs professors in
hospitals
everywhere
doctors you're
talking out out of your bottoms you have
no idea you have no idea and you're all
chanting from The River To The Sea you
don't know what
river you don't know your history you
don't know your
geography because they're saying from
The River To The Sea well if you had any
idea of geography you could work out
where this little country is and go oh
it's the med terranean sea but they
don't know that
educated Harvard students University
students I'm sorry you can cut out the
Harvard bit educated Harvard educated
University students and they don't even
know what river or what sea
borders
Israel yeah they're probably very
educated in their specific subject but
don't know anything else around it there
are some people many people actually who
want to try and downplay what happened
on October the 7th who think the stories
have been exaggerated that women weren't
raped that people weren't beheaded that
you know everything has been exaggerated
what do you say to
them um what do I say to him it it
really doesn't matter what I say does it
it really doesn't matter what I
say all the
footage that that you see of that day
and days afterwards that's Hamas body
cams that's Hamas body cams they were
streaming it they were proud of
it if you could just ask her how did she
feel when she saw you and realized you
were alive and you were there for her
happy happy she says
happy you know what that's all she
needed to say and it's been uh and she
smiled
y she was she says she was very happy
and and smiled
yeah an extraordinary interview with a
remarkable man and his even more
remarkable daughter well coming up the
first votes in the 202 2024 election the
cast as irans picked their nominee for
president can anyone stop Donald Trump
as uncensored next live from New York
[Music]
City
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online on
your smart speaker as well criminals to
using XL Bully dogs as weapons to
threaten others no matter how well
trained most dog owners will tell you a
dog can turn you know what I love about
talk today we do it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tour is love of scrap
you can almost see this coming around
the tracks with sella bravman she's
heading up one side and richy soon at
the other the police are pro Palestine
that is just not right you swear an off
in the police to act without fear or
favor the co inquiry seems to have
turned into a sort of pantomim there's
not really any substance to it it's hard
to know whether it's a fce or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's costus we're saying what are
we saying it's cost about 140 million
£40 million so far so £40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from K in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking liit if you're towards me and
you're a vegan she have a great big
orange sticker over here saying watch
out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC mous man MC mous
man MC mous man he should be easy enough
to catch this guy shouldn't he I mean
he's got a house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
film sunak and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on behalf of Reform UK party
hi kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem Sol this is really
unfair what what what's unfair if it's
on camera we're not doing interviews yes
I'm going to do I'm you're going to
resol yes cuz I cannot continue my work
when I say I am God I'm not joking did
you feel Elvis was trolling I've been
answering your question you answer mine
it's actually not my job to answer your
questions are you prepared to call h a
terror group is it possible to have a
rational I've asked you two questions
should a mass stay in power and are they
a terror group you're refusing to answer
either of them that is very telling talk
TV is the only place where you get the
truth you've done a book on poetry
poetry and music for the many I love
poetry we can agree on
that
coming up on the independent republic of
mik gr Maggie Oliver is here she's going
to be talking to us about the rosdale
grooming Scandal Peter Hitchens is also
here he's going to be telling us why we
should not be looking at going to war in
the Middle East plus we're talking to
Ivon Tracy the ex poost ministers who's
going to unseat Sir Ed Davy at the next
election you don't want to miss it this
is the independent republic of Mike
Graham
welcome back to uncensored live from New
York City as the race for the White
House officially gets
underway well voters across the
Midwestern State of Iowa will this
evening Brave very very cold
temperatures maybe the coldest ever for
an Iowa caucus to select their
Republican candidate former president
Donald Trump is expected to crush the
field with potentially as much as 50% of
the vote which would be an all record
but can it be stopped and other polls
wrong joining me now in the studio
former conservative MP Louise mench and
journalist Emily Austin and polical
strategist and pulst to Frank Lance is
in Iowa before we go to Frank who's
probably freezing to slow uh Extinction
over there in Iowa let's come just
quickly to Emily and Lise just get a
reaction to that interview with Thomas
hand with his daughter there I was
struck by how she wanted to be there
with him she never stopped stroking his
face particularly when he cried got
angry really powerful there are some
Fates worse than death and what you saw
there was a father looking down the
barrel at what could have happened to
his little girl and I think when people
forget what actually happened what
kicked off this entire War they're
forgetting that these terrorists took a
little girl hostage and put her father
through that and she was one of the
lucky ones horrible to say but some
13-year-old girls didn't Faire as well
as that poor little child there still a
baby missing now we've no idea really
what's happened to that baby or
countless other people Emily what did
you make of it I just remember grieving
along with the most of the world when we
thought Emily was dead and then
celebrating when we found out she's
alive but still don't really know her
fate and to watch like you just said
watching her comfort her dad when she's
the one who went through the trauma as
well as he um just shows you the
resilience of kids and like it's sad to
say she's too young to remember but we
were discussing in The Green Room this
is something that's going to haunt her
for life and it's you know I sent him a
text just now saying getting an amazing
reaction to that interviewed Thomas and
I said you are an extraordinary man and
he replied I I'm not I'm just an
ordinary person trying to deal with this
like everybody else which I thought was
typically modest of him but actually
he's right you know these were just
ordinary people living in a kabut we
didn't know who they were and now
forever they will be part of the history
of this horror that's been unfurling um
let me go to to to Frank um Frank let's
let's segue into the election in uh Iowa
where it all kicks off for real I've
going to say as a Brit from across the
pond it always seems a bit weird your
system that so much seems to hinge on
Iowa and the strange way they do this
sell it to
me well I'm not going to sell it to you
I actually want to hearken back to that
interview I've had the chance to listen
to the last 10 minutes of it and it
makes me angry at the politicians over
here in America tearing each other apart
over nothing insulting each other being
rude and abusing
that surely when we see these crises
that are happening in other parts of the
globe why we must behave like idiots and
how bad it makes America look so no I
don't want to sell Iowa I do want to say
that Iowa voters are more sophisticated
than average they take the
responsibilities very seriously they do
care about the outcome Donald Trump is
likely to get about half the vote the
big question is who comes in second
because that individual gets bragging
rights for the state that really matters
New Hampshire uh Piers Iowa makes a
statement New Hampshire makes a
difference and it's just a shame that
the statement is being made in weather
that's 15 degrees below
zero that presumably will help Trump
simply because if you look at all the
polling yes Niki Haley's got a bit of
momentum and replaced DeSantis into
second place but if you get into the
weeds of the of the data the uh sort of
very positive uh enthusiasm for
candidates Trump roaring ahead at nearly
90% the santis second Nikki Haley pretty
low on enthusiasm if actually it comes
down to who's going to get out of the
warm comfortable home and go and vote in
these conditions you've got to think it
helps Trump and may actually help the
santz a
bit well it it I think it might hurt
Trump because his vote is pretty old and
if you're over 75 going out in this
weather is actually dangerous for you
and I think it hurts the vake ramaswami
because even though he's hasn't been
talked about as much his vote is 18 to
29 year olds and they're less likely to
vote in the end Trump is going to win
big whether he crosses that 50%
threshold we don't know the votes have
to be counted but also in the end it's
amazing to me that Donald Trump in most
surveys is leading Joe Biden even though
Trump has been indicted 91 times even
though he's been thrown off at two
ballots even though the campaign against
him has been so vicious because he
himself has turned himself into a victim
into someone who's not prosecuted but
persecuted and right now you have to
give Trump the narrow advantage in
November despite the primaries and
caucuses and all this chaos that's
around American politics yeah it's it's
quite extraordinary it's unprecedented
Emily I want to play a little clip this
is of Donald Trump last night trying to
get his vote out and making a typical
Trump
remark you can't sit
home if you're sick as a dog you say
darling I'm got to make it even if you
vote and then pass away it's worth
it now look we're all laughing right and
that's the reaction I watched this my
old CNN colleagues trying to be serious
about this and I couldn't help
themselves but laughing this Emily is
his trump card literally is that he is
funnier than the other candidates and as
we've seen with Boris Johnson in the UK
who became prime minister if you've got
a sense of humor you don't talk or
behave like other politicians you can go
a long way and you can make a comeback
like Trump yeah I mean being being 22
years old in gen Z's epitome I I grew up
in a trump election 2016 was the first
election I can recall Trump won that
2020 Trump participated lost but being
gen Z I grew up watching Trump and to me
it was always just yes he says it as he
pleases and he doesn't really think
twice before speaking which is a
blessing and a curse you get the
transparency but you also sometimes need
a filter especially on a global stage
and I think it comes down to a balance
the famous quote to be loved or to be
feared now internationally you have to
be feared otherwise you risk being taken
advantage of and being a vulnerable
country which America is very vulnerable
right now but at the same time you risk
Trump winning might you know even prompt
a civil war within America which nobody
benefits from of course the other great
Advantage Trump has and why we may be
seeing this extraordinary comeback is
that Biden looks so week record low
approval ratings again this week and
they're already terrible um a lot of
Democrats two-thirds of them don't think
you should run again but he is and if he
does you got to think Trump has a great
chance I don't think Trump has a great
chance honestly I don't think polls this
far out for the general election mean
very much we've seen it over and over
again that said Joe Biden should not
make Hillary Clinton's mistake and start
being complacent in 2020 Joe Biden won
because he wasn't Trump time for a
change is the most effective slogan in
politics all the time forever now it's
time for a change from Biden so he's got
to be careful he's got to be cautious
the Democrats the White House will be
looking at the results of this caucus
with with great interest very great
interest is the race for second place
only Nikki Haley has really managed
expectations she said that New
Hampshire's her big state if she manages
to outperform she could get a bit of a
mention just in case the Supreme Court
throws a monkey wrench into Donald
Trump's all right Frank Lun no one knows
about polling better than you uh what
what are the possible scenarios here
could we see one maybe two candidates
dropping out by the time Iowa's come out
in the
wash absolutely Ronda Sanders cannot
justify continuing after spending more
than a hundred million and most of that
here in Iowa if he comes in third I
can't imagine him going Beyond tomorrow
and then you also have to look of aake
ramaswami who's self-funding his
campaign does he get over 10% of the
votes which indicates that there's still
some rationale for his campaign and then
you have ASA Hinson who most Brits will
never heard of because most Americans
have never heard of him he's a former
Governor successful Governor at that and
no one he's getting zero point or I
should say not 7% of the votes uh once
again I agree with with your colleague
that you don't trust the polling this
early in the campaign but make no
mistake it's going to be more negative
than it's ever been it's going to be
more personal more vicious and more
Americans are going to say to hell with
American politics and American elections
as the months continue okay prediction
time what's going to happen here Emily I
politely disagree with you because I
don't think Biden's given Americans
enough of an incentive to vote for him
again Biden wins it's purely out of I
think if it's Biden Trump trump wins me
too I think Trump's and I wouldn't have
said that a year ago but you gotta say
the guy's resilience I will say with
Trump he has the thinnest skin of any
human being I've met in my life he
reacts he reacts to everything right but
he has the thickest he can soak up stuff
that would crush any other politician
and Louise you've been a politician if
you've got that thick skin like Trump
and you can SWAT away all the buzzards
and the Flies you've got a great chance
people like always like a political
candidate who just speaks his mind and
doesn't give a damn I know you're not a
big fan of Boris Johnson but he had that
quality Trump has that quality he was
obviously joking when he said you know
go out and die for me to vote the fact
is he's I think that Biden will beat
Trump quite handily but I think Trump is
the only candidate that Biden could
could be okay let's go quickly back to
Frank before he literally freezes to
death in front of us Frank if it's Biden
Trump can you see way Biden
wins well I want to separate Donald
Trump from Boris Johnson Boris has
written more books than Donald Trump has
read I believe that the is way too that
the election is way too close to call
that either candidate can win and if you
force me to bend on it now I would bet
that Donald Trump would come out
slightly ahead because his voters are
passionate yeah they are Frank L great
to see you and thank you for braving the
elements thank you to Louise and to
Emily lovely to see you both again
that's it for me what you up to Keep It
Uncensored good
night
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online on
your smart speaker as well they have
made a statement condemning Hamas we
expect to see the crown revisit Harry's
anti-semitic Halloween costume criminals
to using XL Bully dogs as weapons to
threaten others no matter how well
trained most dog owners will tell you a
dog can turn you know what I love about
talk today we do it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the Israelis are very
conciliatory all they want is to be
recognized the timing of this hamus
attack comes because there was the
expectation there was going to be a deal
done to normalizing relations with Saudi
Arabia the Tories love a scrap you can
almost see this coming around the tracks
with sella bravman she's heading up one
side and soon at the other reshuffles
usually very dull this one had booster
Rockets attached to it certainly the
tone has shifted in terms of what Ry
suak has done the question now is what
he does next the police are pro
Palestine that is just not right you
swearing o in the police to act without
fear or favor the co inquiry seems to
have turned into a sort of pantomim
there's not really any substance to it
it's hard to know whether it's a fce or
a tragedy talk TV has spoken exclusively
to a member of the Blade Runners do you
have a message for or Sadi Khan we're
not stopping until you
stop the amount of time it's taken the
number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million £140
million pound so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold
that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking for liit if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan should
have a great big orange sticker over
here saying watch out vegans
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC mous man MC mous
man MC M he should be easy enough to
catch this guy shouldn't he I mean he's
got house full of
this is a major Summit President Biden
decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz film do